Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 92. Ausgabe dieser Gesprächsreihe,
wo wir immer über ganz viel wichtige Sachen sprechen und manchmal geht es extrem ins Detail
und manchmal bewegt man sich dann doch mehr auf der Metaebene,
das wird heute wahrscheinlich so eine Sendung werden,
denn wir wollen über Innovation sprechen und auch über Kreativität
und noch ein paar andere interessante Begriffe und Tätigkeiten.
Und dazu begrüße ich erst mal meine Gesprächspartnerin heute,
nämlich Katharina Hölzle, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, ich freue mich, da zu sein.
Ich freue mich, hier zu sein, denn ich bin ja eigentlich der Gast.
Ich bin nach Potsdam gefahren, denn dort sind Sie Professorin für IT-Entrepreneurship, wie das so schön heißt.
Was Teil der Digital Engineering Fakultät ist an der Universität Potsdam.
Soweit stimmt das, aber jetzt wird es kompliziert,
das Ganze hat auch noch eine Verbindung mit dem Hasso Plattner Institut.
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach zu erklären oder doch?
Ich versuche es mal ganz einfach.
Also das ist das Hasso Plattner Institut, welches ja vor über 20 Jahren von Hasso Plattner gegründet wurde.
Was dann ganz lange ein Aninstitut an der Universität Potsdam war
und dann vor gut drei Jahren in die Universität Potsdam aufgenommen wurde als Digital Engineering Fakultät.
Ah. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen in die Universität hineingewachsen?
Genau.
Ja und Hasso Plattner hat ja Kraft seiner Herkunft, sagen wir mal, digitale Themen
und Bildungsthemen auch früh hier in den Fokus gestellt des Instituts
und es hat sich dann mittlerweile ziemlich ausgewachsen hier an der Uni Potsdam,
kann man sagen oder?
Richtig, genau. Also wir sind ja relativ klein gestartet mit knapp zehn Kollegen,
zehn Professoren und dann bin ich vor jetzt gut zwei Jahren dazugekommen
als erste weibliche Professorin und auch als erste nicht-Informatikprofessorin,
denn vorher war das halt immer Kern die sogenannte angewandte Informatik.
Und dann bin eben vor zwei Jahren ich dazugekommen
und der Kollege Übernickel, der das Themenfeld Innovation und Design Thinking, Forschung macht,
und das waren die ersten beiden, die sich dann mal so ein bisschen interdisziplinär da drüber gelegt haben,
um die Themen auch mal im Kontext und übergreifend zu sehen.
Und aktuell sind wir jetzt nach letzter Zählung 24 Professoren und zwei Professorinnen
und es sollen jetzt noch zwei, drei dazukommen und dann sind wir aber erst mal ausgewachsen.
So da soll es dann erst mal so bleiben.
Da merkt man schon wieder das Problem, was die Informatik nicht nur in Deutschland,
aber auch in Deutschland, schon immer hat, dass es dann doch sehr männlichlastig war lange lange Zeit.
Ja.
Bricht langsam auf?
Nicht wirklich.
Also es ist wirklich wirklich sehr langsam, es ist ein sehr dickes Brett.
Ich hätte das vorher auch nicht gedacht, ich komme ja selber aus den Ingenieurswissenschaften,
da sind wir gefühlt tatsächlich schon 10-15 Jahre weiter.
Da haben wir schon eine größere Heterogenität und Diversität.
Die Informatik hat da immer noch wirklich Schwierigkeiten.
Ich bin ja auch Mitglied der SheTransformsIT Initiative,
wo wir ja auch mit Mitgliedern aus Wirtschaft, Wissenschaft, Politik versuchen,
dieses Thema echt ganz oben auf die Agenda zu setzen.
Ich glaube, da ist es, aber über diese 15 Prozent Frauenanteil kommen wir irgendwie seit Jahren nicht wirklich raus.
Und wir bemühen uns sehr und ich habe auch immer das Gefühl,
wir haben viele zarte Pflänzchen, wir gehen in die Schulen,
wir gehen also in die Kindergärten noch nicht, aber versuchen,
da wirklich schon frühzeitig anzufangen, aber da muss sich wirklich noch sehr sehr viel ändern.
Ist das noch so ein bisschen Henne-Ei-Problem, dass es auch ein bisschen was mit dem Angebot von unten zu tun hat
oder ist das eher ein strukturelles Problem von oben?
Ja wahrscheinlich beides.
Also es kommen halt ganz viele Faktoren zusammen.
Es fehlen uns die Rollenmodelle, es fehlen uns die Frauen, die da stehen,
mit denen sich die jungen Frauen, die Mädchen identifizieren können.
Gleichzeitig ist es so, dass wir insgesamt im Kontext MINT einfach,
das wissen Sie sicherlich noch besser als ich, ein totales Bildungsproblem haben.
Das ist eine schwierig anzufassende Wissenschaft.
Und bei Informatik kommt es dann noch mal stärker dazu.
Dass es häufig eben immer damit assoziiert wird, es geht um programmieren,
es geht um die Nerds, die im Keller sitzen und das ist etwas,
damit holen Sie Mädchen grundsätzlich nicht so schnell hervor,
da haben die nicht so viel Lust drauf.
Was wir sehen sind die Bindestrich-Informatiken.
Wirtschafts-Informatik, Bio-Informatik, Medien-Informatik,
da ist der Frauenanteil deutlich höher, da sind wir mittlerweile schon bei 30-40 Prozent angekommen.
Also das heißt, wenn wir das Ganze verbinden mit einem Sinn,
mit einer Anwendung, mit dem Thema Impact, da sind wir ja schon so ein bisschen bei dem Innovationsthema,
da klappt es besser, ja.
Aber so die Kerninformatik und so, das ist schwierig und genau,
wir haben gerade bei der Schule angefangen und das setzt sich dann aber leider so fort,
dass wir eben auch an den Universitäten sehen, dass selbst wenn wir die Mädchen,
die jungen Frauen haben, die anfangen Informatik zu studieren,
dass die sehr sehr zu kämpfen haben, weil es doch immer noch sehr programmierlastig ist.
Die Jungs können alle programmieren, die Mädchen können nicht programmieren
und da müssen wir einfach noch mehr Angebote schaffen und dann sagen,
ja es gibt tatsächlich Mädchenprogrammierkurse, damit die einfach erst mal ankommen.
Ja, das gibt mir Anlass und Gelegenheit, mal nach Ihrem eigenen Werdegang zu fragen.
Sie haben ja eigentlich so ein bisschen mit der Wirtschaft angefangen,
kann man das so formulieren?
ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt schon beim Studium starten sollte,
mich interessiert immer so ein bisschen die Motivation eigentlich,
warum man ja ein bestimmtes Studium überhaupt erst einschlägt.
Also bei Ihnen war das dann die Wirtschaftsingenieurwissenschaften richtig?
Richtig.
Wie kommt man da drauf?
Man kommt darauf, wenn der eigene Vater Unternehmer ist
und man selber aber gesehen hat, wie er gestrampelt hat,
wie schwer das war, wie eng auch häufig das Geld war,
dass das für mich nie ein Karriereweg war.
Dass ich gesagt habe, nein das möchte ich nicht.
Ich finde die Wirtschaft spannend, ich habe es kennengelernt bei meinem Vater,
habe natürlich da auch viel mitgearbeitet, aber wollte auf gar keinen Fall BWL studieren,
weil ich die BWLer damals schwierig fand.
Ich hatte Mathe, Chemie Leistungskurs.
Ich glaube, wenn ich aus einem klassischen Akademikerhaushalt gekommen wäre,
was wir nicht waren, dann hätte ich vielleicht sogar Ingenieurwesen studieren können,
das ist so etwas, was ich immer noch ein bisschen bedaure,
dass ich nicht mehr Mut hatte, tatsächlich in die Ingenieurwissenschaften einzusteigen.
Und der Wirtschaftsingenieur das war dann so der praktische Wirtschaftswissenschaftler auf der einen.
Und auf der anderen Seite …
Die Bindestrich-Disziplin.
Genau, also vielleicht ganz vergleichbar.
Und wie muss man das verstehen, also Wirtschaftsingenieur, wo liegt der Schwerpunkt?
Naja, also im Grundstudium ist er erst mal schön bunt.
Ich habe ja noch ein klassisches Diplom gemacht in Karlsruhe an der Technischen Universität.
Und da haben Sie natürlich von Mathe 1 bis 3b über die Physik,
über die Chemie, über die Materialwissenschaften alles dabei.
Und dann auch so ein bisschen die auch Programmierung, Rechnungswesen
und dann im Hauptstudium habe ich mich dann auf der einen Seite
im Bereich der Ingenieurswissenschaften hatte ich den Maschinenbau
und auch wieder die Materialwissenschaften.
Und auf der anderen Seite dann, das war die Karlsruher Prägung,
aber auch immer schon Informatik, Operations Research und Wirtschaftswissenschaften.
Und letztendlich …
Das war Universität Karlsruhe dann?
Genau, so und uns wurde dann immer vorgeworfen, das wird dem Wirtschaftsingenieur immer gerne noch vorgeworfen,
das ist die eierlegende Wollmilchsau, kann alles so ein bisschen, aber nichts richtig.
Das kann auch ein Vorteil sein.
Genau.
Dann ging es aber in die Wirtschaft für Sie erst mal?
Genau, also ich hatte das große Glück, dass ich ein Jahr im Ausland studieren durfte.
Ich habe in den USA meinen Master of Business Administration gemacht
und hatte dort Professoren, die eigentlich alle aus der Wirtschaft kamen.
Die hatten alle mal in Unternehmen gearbeitet und das war für mich eine ganz neue Welt.
Das war also nicht mehr so viel Theorie wie in Karlsruhe,
sondern das war wirklich Hands on, wie man so sagen kann.
Und das war für mich der Punkt, dass ich sagte, ich habe während meines Studiums immer schon an einem Lehrstuhl gearbeitet,
was mir große Freude gemacht hat, aber ich fand dieses Vorbild aus den USA,
dass die Professoren eben wirklich wussten worüber sie sprachen, das fand ich toll.
Und da war der Punkt, dass ich sagte, ich kann mir vorstellen, in die Academia zu gehen.
Aber ich möchte doch gerne noch erst die andere Seite sehen, ich möchte erst noch mal richtig arbeiten.
Und so kam dann die Entscheidung, zunächst einmal in die Wirtschaft zu gehen.
Und als ich dann diverse Stationen durchlaufen hatte, vom Großunternehmen Siemens
über die Unternehmensberatung, Capgemini, bis hin zu einem amerikanischen Startup-Unternehmen,
war dann irgendwann der Punkt gekommen, dass ich gesagt habe, so jetzt hast du alles mal gesehen
und jetzt bist du eigentlich bereit, das Ganze jetzt noch mal von der wissenschaftlichen Seite zu betrachten.
Startup und Siemens und so, das sind ja, also das könnte ja kaum weiter voneinander entfernt sein.
Ich will jetzt Siemens nicht zu nahe treten, aber ist natürlich eine ganz andere Struktur.
Also klar, wenn ich jetzt frage, wo nimmt man mehr mit, dann ist die Antwort,
beides ist lehrreich, aber was prägt einen letztlich vielleicht mehr?
Also am meisten geprägt hat mich tatsächlich die Zeit in der Unternehmensberatung.
Das war eine sehr harte Zeit, also das ist tatsächlich eigentlich noch mal eine zusätzliche Ausbildung gewesen.
Ich bin da sehr geschliffen worden, das tat auch teilweise ganz schön weh,
aber ich glaube, ich habe da wirklich sehr sehr viel noch mal gelernt.
Und das war ja so das Zwischenstück, zwischen dem Großunternehmen und dann dem Startup.
Und die anderen beiden Erfahrungen waren sehr unterschiedlich, aber beide gut.
Also ich glaube, wenn ich nicht vorher in einem Großunternehmen gearbeitet hätte,
dann hätte ich auf Unternehmensberaterseite nicht so gut verstanden, wie ein Unternehmen tickt,
in welchen Strukturen es häufig gefangen ist.
Und wenn ich nicht als Unternehmensberaterin auch gelernt hätte, so selbstständig zu arbeiten,
dann hätte ich in diesem amerikanischen Startup-Unternehmen,
wo ich ja dann am Ende dafür verantwortlich war, auch die europäische Tochter aufzubauen,
hätte ich das nicht so selbständig machen können.
Was für ein Startup war das?
Das nannte sich „Need2Buy“, das war eine Plattform für die Halbleiterindustrie.
Und das war also im Jahr 2000, die Hochzeit des e-Commerce,
und der Halbleitermarkt war damals, was er heute auch immer noch ist, sehr volatil,
er war sehr intransparent und die Zielsetzung, mit der wir rangegangen waren,
war es, eine Plattform zu schaffen, um Nachfrage und Angebot besser zusammenzubringen.
Wenn man geschliffen wird in der Unternehmensberatung, was schleift sich da ab und wer schleift da an einem?
Naja, erst einmal natürlich die verantwortlichen Partner auf dem Projekt, die einem sehr genau sagen,
wo man sich einzuordnen hat und was von einem erwartet wird.
Sei es die Form, der Inhalt einer Präsentation, die Art und Weise wie man professionell beim Kunden auftritt.
Also insofern würde ich eher sagen, schleifen im positiven Sinne, also einen Rohdiamanten in Form bringen.
Eine Härtung eher.
Was schleift sich ab.
Also dadurch, dass es bei mir nur gut anderthalb Jahre waren, hat sich nicht so viel abgeschliffen,
sondern es hat sich tatsächlich viel herausgeschliffen.
Okay, verstehe.
Und dann ging es aber doch eher wieder in die Richtung der Universitäten?
Genau, also, wie sagt man, das Spiel oder die Tätigkeit bei dem Startup-Unternehmen das endete,
nachdem die amerikanische Mutter festgestellt hatte, dass die europäische Tochter doch nicht so wichtig ist,
wie sie das vielleicht geglaubt hat.
Ich hatte dann das Angebot, in den USA weiterzuarbeiten und da war für mich aber der Punkt,
dass ich dachte, so jetzt hast du viel gesehen, das wäre auch spannend gewesen,
aber mein damaliger Professur, für den ich schon in Karlsruhe gearbeitet hatte,
der war nach Berlin gegangen, ich lebte zu der Zeit theoretisch in Berlin
und machte mir ein Angebot und sagte, Mensch wie sieht es denn aus?
So, ich habe dich nicht vergessen, ich habe da jetzt gerade eine Stelle frei, hast du nicht Lust?
Und das war für mich so der Punkt, dass ich dachte, ja, jetzt ist der an der Technischen Universität Berlin,
er hatte ein konkretes Projekt mit der Robert Bosch GmbH zusammen, das passte dann auch gut zu diesem Thema.
Auch immer noch in derselben Disziplin?
Genau, Innovationsmanagement.
Also er hatte den Lehrstuhl für Technologie und Innovationsmanagement,
es war eine Promotion im Kontext des Projektmanagements, also Laufbahn für Projektleiter zu entwerfen.
Und das passte sehr gut zu meinem Anspruch, die Verbinderin, die Vermittlerin zwischen Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft zu sein.
Also das gleiche wie jetzt, aber nicht das gleiche wie vorher, also nichts Wirtschaftsingenieurwissenschaften,
sondern halt jetzt ging es in die Innovation rein.
Und wie kam es dann zu dem Engagement hier?
Na, ich habe dann an der TU Berlin meine Promotion absolviert, also meine Dissertation geschrieben,
bin dann kurzzeitig bei dem Professor Gemünden als Postdoc beschäftigt gewesen
und habe dann eine Juniorprofessur an der TU Berlin angenommen.
Auch das war wieder Mittlerin zwischen Wirtschaft und Wissenschaft,
eine Juniorprofessur die von den Deutschen Telekom Laboratories finanziert war,
die T-Labs waren damals, das war 2007, da gab es die schon ein paar Jahre,
das war ja eine ausgelagerte Forschungseinheit der Deutschen Telekom,
angesiedelt an der TU Berlin, mit dem Auftrag, denkt neu.
Da sind wir schon bei dem Thema kreativ, innovativ, denkt außerhalb der Strukturen der klassischen Deutschen Telekom.
Und ich hatte die Juniorprofessur für Organisation und Führung im Innovationsmanagement.
So und das habe ich dann gute anderthalb Jahre gemacht und dann war die Professur für Innovationsmanagement und Entrepreneurship
an der Universität Potsdam ausgeschrieben und ich habe einfach mal meinen Hut in den Ring geworfen,
fand mich selber noch ein bisschen jung, aber hat funktioniert und so bin ich dann 2011 an die Universität Potsdam gegangen.
Hatte damals schon an der School of Design Thinking des Hasso-Plattner-Instituts als Dozentin, als Coach gearbeitet.
Habe dann angefangen, am Hasso-Plattner-Institut die Bachelor- und Masterstudenten im Kontext Wirtschaft und Gründung zu unterrichten.
Habe da immer sehr viel Spaß gehabt an den Studierenden, weil die sehr aufgeweckt,
sehr wissbegierig und gleichzeitig eben diesen technischen Hintergrund,
der mir dann bei der klassischen BWL ein bisschen fehlte, hatte.
Und als dann 2018 die Professur für IT-Entrepreneurship am HPI ausgeschrieben war,
habe ich mich darauf beworben und bin dann am 01. November 2019 eben richtig als Professorin für IT-Entrepreneurship ans Hasso-Plattner-Institut gegangen.
Was heißt denn, man fühlt sich zu jung für eine Professur?
Hat das immer noch den Nimbus, man muss steinalt sein, um so was zu übernehmen?
Ja, also das menschliche Alter hat sich zum Glück so ein bisschen, glaube ich, verändert.
Wir haben da ja, gut, wir haben in Deutschland immer noch sehr lineare akademische Laufbahnen.
Also meine Laufbahn ist da ja doch immer noch sehr unüblich, zumindest in vielen Bereichen.
Vielleicht nicht bei den Ingenieurswissenschaften, aber in anderen Disziplinen schon,
insofern als dass ich ja die Academia erst mal verlassen hatte,
insofern war ich eigentlich vom zeitlichen Alter gar nicht mehr so jung,
denn ich hatte ja schon diesen Interimspart gehabt, aber ich war ja nun erst anderthalb Jahre als Juniorprofessorin tätig.
Und insofern das akademische Alter war eben noch nicht so hoch.
So, das heißt, jetzt in der neuen Rolle hier in Potsdam wird natürlich gelernt, aber es wird natürlich auch geforscht,
so wie sich das gehört und mit so Begriffen wie Innovation und Kreativität und Unternehmen
ist ja auch eine mutige Kombination, erfüllt ja nicht unbedingt jetzt jedes Unternehmen.
Reden immer alle ganz gerne davon, aber die Frage ist natürlich, was ist das denn eigentlich?
Wenn man jetzt daran forscht und wenn man da, sagen wir mal, jetzt auch wirklich versucht,
strukturiert heranzugehen, muss es ja auch erst mal einen Definitionsrahmen geben.
Man muss es ja irgendwie fassen.
Es ist natürlich immer ein super Wort für Sonntagsreden, aber wenn es konkret wird,
ein Paper dabei rauskommen soll, muss man das natürlich schon so ein bisschen einkreisen.
Vielleicht können wir uns da mal kurz daran versuchen, was durch Innovation jetzt eigentlich wirklich abgedeckt ist.
Was muss man sich, was stellen Sie sich darunter vor?
Also für mich ist Innovation erst mal die Umsetzung einer Idee in etwas anfassbares.
Also es ist mehr als die Idee, es ist mehr als ein Konzert, was vielleicht meine Idee schon mal beschreibt,
sondern ich habe das schon in irgendeiner Weise anfassbar gemacht
und ich habe Menschen, sage ich jetzt mal breit noch gesprochen, gefunden,
die das annehmen, die das umsetzen, die damit irgendetwas anfangen.
Ich mache jetzt den Rahmen noch mal ein bisschen größer.
In der klassischen Definition sind Innovationen immer etwas, die im Markt umgesetzt werden.
Also wir sprechen von der Idee, von dem Konzept und dann erst von der Innovation,
wenn es in den Markt gebracht wurde und der Markt es angenommen hat.
Ich glaube aber, dass wenn wir heute von Innovation sprechen,
dass wir diesen Markt sehr viel weiter fassen müssen.
Denn der Markt ist erst mal ein sehr wirtschaftlicher Begriff.
Und ich glaube, dass, wenn wir eben darüber nachdenken, deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade Menschen gesagt,
wir ja auch über Gesellschaften sprechen oder über Politiksysteme.
Also wichtig ist einfach nur, die Innovation ist mehr als nur eine fixe Idee,
eine Problemlösung, ein Konzept, sondern es muss umgesetzt sein.
So und über diesen Grad der Umsetzung, darüber können sowohl die Experten als auch die nicht-Experten trefflich streiten.
Aber es muss am Ende etwas anfassbares da sein, was mehr als nur ich,
als der Erfinder, die Erfinderin gut findet.
Würde mir jetzt so als erstes die aktuelle Situation rund um Energiegewinnung einfallen.
Ist ja im Prinzip auch ein sehr innovationsträchtiger Bereich.
Also es gibt eine gesellschaftliche Notwendigkeit für eine Innovation, für die aber ein Markt in dem Sinne noch nicht existiert
oder teilweise existiert er eben schon oder befinden wir uns mittlerweile natürlich in einer Phase,
wo der in zunehmendem Maße wächst, aber wenn man noch mal 20 Jahre zurückblickt,
als das erneuerbare Energien Gesetz kam, war das ja im Prinzip so ein Ansatz.
Ist das das, was Sie meinen?
Mit der Umsetzung, ja, grundsätzlich schon.
Also natürlich, wenn wir jetzt eben drüber nachdenken, dann wissen wir ja auch,
es hat schon viele Erfindungen gegeben, die womöglich auch Menschen gefunden haben,
die gesagt haben, das ist eine supercoole Idee, genauso sollten wir das machen.
Also zum Beispiel auch jetzt aktuell Cryptocurrencies oder wie bezahlen wir eigentlich.
Hier die Electronic Wallets, da hat es also vor 20 Jahren schon Lösungen gegeben,
die fanden Leute auch cool, da gab es also auch eine technische Umsetzung,
aber die große Masse hat es eben noch nicht angenommen.
Und genauso können wir jetzt bei den erneuerbaren Energien ja ähnlich darüber nachdenken,
dass wir sagen, also eigentlich haben wir die Lösungen, aber sie werden ja noch nicht wirklich breit umgesetzt in einem Markt, in einer Gesellschaft.
So und dann kommen wir natürlich ganz schnell auf die Ebene der Diskussion,
welche Rolle spielt dann beispielsweise der Staat, in dem er dann einen Markt schafft
bzw. eine solche Innovation zunächst einmal trägt.
Denn ich sagte ja gerade schon, diese klassische Wirtschaftsdefinition,
eine Innovation hat einen Markt, das ist natürlich genau dieser Marktbegriff
und darüber können wir ja trefflich streiten, wer schafft Innovationen?
Ist das der Markt, sind das die Unternehmen oder um eben beispielsweise mit Mariana Mazzucato zu sprechen,
ist es der Staat, der ein ganz großer Innovationstreiber ist.
Und da sehen wir schon, es ist schwierig, da dann zu definieren, wer schafft diesen Markt,
wer ist eigentlich der Nachfrager und ab wann können wir sagen, das ist jetzt eine Innovation.
Und da versuchen wir uns als Innovationsforscher immer noch ein bisschen zu behelfen,
dass wir sagen, es kommt auf die Art der Innovation an, es kommt auf den Grad der Innovation an,
es kommt auf die Nachfragenden an.
Nur weil es für Sie jetzt gerade eine Innovation ist, ist es vielleicht für mich keine und umgekehrt.
Also dieser Innovationsbegriff und das ist so spannend daran, das stelle ich sowohl hier an meinen Kollegen, an meinen Studierenden fest,
als auch in den klassischen Ingenieurwissenschaften, die Naturwissenschaften sind es gewohnt,
1 oder 0 zu sagen, es ist richtig oder es ist falsch, es gibt klare Antworten.
Die Innovation ist nie schwarz oder weiß, sie ist nie ja oder nein,
sondern sie ist sehr häufig so, dass wir sagen, es kommt darauf an.
Nur weil Deutschland jetzt für sich beschlossen hat, dass wir mit dem erneuerbaren Energie Gesetz folgende Technologien fördern wollen
und daraus entsprechende Innovation machen, ist das in einem Land wie Japan beispielsweise oder China
noch lange nicht diese Innovation wie wir sie vielleicht sehen und umgekehrt.
Wenn man, jetzt gibt es ja noch den zweiten Begriff der Kreativität, der diese Innovation offensichtlich befördern soll,
ist das auch ein definierbarer Begriff?
Der ist noch mal schwieriger.
Ja, ich weiß, deswegen habe ich das ich gefragt.
Hier gehen wir nämlich dann von den Wirtschaftswissenschaften, die ja vielleicht noch so ein bisschen ihre Wurzeln in den Naturwissenschaften haben,
gehen wir ja jetzt in die Sozial- und Geisteswissenschaften, wir gehen in die Verhaltenswissenschaften,
wir gehen gerade bei der Kreativität auch schnell in die Hirnforschung beispielsweise.
Was ist Kreativität, was macht ein kreativen Menschen aus?
So und dann kommen wir in den Bereich der Kunst, wir kommen in den Bereich der Human- und Geisteswissenschaften,
was schaffe ich sozusagen als künstlerisches Werk, wie verändere ich Dinge?
Also die Kreativität ist da noch mal breiter.
Ist das mehr so im Sinne von Produktivität gemeint?
Also ich meine, Kreativität kann ja heißen, man schafft was und das Schaffen als solches ist sozusagen wichtig
oder so wie wir das, sagen wir mal, gemeinhin so diskutieren und benutzen das Wort,
im Sinne von, oh da hast du jetzt aber was gemacht, wo ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen wäre,
was ja eigentlich mehr so diesen Innovationstouch hat, so dieses,
oh wenn jemand sehr kreativ ist, dann tut er innovative Dinge oder ist es einfach nur so ein Output generieren können.
Wie klingt das Wort in Ihrem Kopf?
Also für mich klingt es sehr viel mehr schaffend, also die Problematik mit dem Wort der Produktivität ist,
dass das ja mittlerweile in Teilen negativ konnotiert ist,
weil die Produktivität immer ein klar definiertes Ergebnis hat.
Messbar ist auch.
Und ich meine, das Thema Produktivität und ob sich unsere Produktivität verändert hat oder nicht,
da können wir ja noch mal anderweitig drüber sprechen.
Kreativität für mich hat tatsächlich ganz viel mit dem Wort Schaffen, creare etwas schaffen.
Wie dieses, was wir da schaffen, aussieht, ist ja dann auch wieder einerseits in der Betrachtungsweise des Schaffenden
und der Menschen, die es betrachten.
Also ist das etwas neues, was dort geschaffen wurde?
Und neu ist ja auch immer in der Perspektive des Betrachters, wie neu ist neu?
Was für mich neu ist, ist für jemand anderen nicht neu.
Aber Kreativität hat für mich wirklich erst mal sehr viel damit zu tun,
und das ist sicherlich die positive Konnotation, die ich diesem Wort gebe, ist,
etwas neues zu schaffen, und zwar neu, gerne auf vielen Dimensionen,
aber tatsächlich eben etwas neues zu schaffen.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch einen Schritt weitergehen darf, was für mich immer ganz wichtig ist,
ist aber schon, und da bin ich dann doch wieder wahrscheinlich stärker Naturwissenschaftlerin als Geisteswissenschaftlerin,
dass ich sage, ich erwarte schon, dass es irgendwie einen Impuls setzen kann.
Also Kreativität um der Kreativität Willen damit tue ich mich ein bisschen schwer.
Sondern ich finde das immer, für mich hat es viel damit zu tun, löse ich ein Problem oder eine Herausforderung.
Hier gibt es am HPI auch diesen, ich weiß nicht, hatten wir es schon erwähnt, diesen Bereich des Design Thinkings,
klang, glaube ich, kurz an, ist ja auch so ein skurriles Wort erst mal.
Was ist denn damit gemeint und inwiefern beeinflusst das die Arbeit hier?
Die Arbeit hier beeinflusst es sehr stark.
Das Design Thinking ist für mich, das ist jetzt wieder meine individuelle Definition,
ein Prozess, eine Einstellung, ein sogenannter Mindset und eine Herangehensweise,
Probleme, Nutzer menschenzentriert zu lösen.
Das macht es so schick, wenn man es im Kontext der Naturwissenschaften gerade betrachtet,
aber auch allgemein, dem Thema, wie lösen wir eigentlich die großen Herausforderungen, vor denen wir stehen,
da gibt es immer technische Lösungen, da sind wir in Deutschland super, wir haben ganz klare Ingenieurstraditionen,
naturwissenschaftliche Traditionen, wir sind immer sehr gut, neue Dinge zu erfinden.
Was wir häufig in der Vergangenheit vergessen haben, ist zu fragen, für wen machen wir es eigentlich?
Brauchen die Menschen das eigentlich?
Das ist so das eine und das andere ist, was brauchen die Menschen eigentlich?
So und diesen Menschen in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen, zu sagen, wir haben tolle Technologien,
wir müssen uns natürlich auch irgendwie die Wirtschaftsseite angucken, weil wir da irgendwann irgendwie mit Geld verdienen müssen
und unsere Arbeitnehmerinnen bezahlen und dann den Menschen mit reinzunehmen.
Wenn wir also diese drei Bälle zusammenpacken, dann entsteht Innovation.
Und Innovation entsteht eben wie gesagt nur dann, wenn wir diese drei Teile miteinander verbinden.
Und ich jetzt als klassischer Wirtschaftsingenieur würde sagen, Technologie und Wirtschaft habe ich gelernt,
während meines Studiums, habe ich angewandt, kann ich.
Den Menschen haben wir erstaunlich wenig betrachtet und das ist das, wo das Design Thinking reinkommt.
Da würde mir ja als erstes mal einfallen, dass eigentlich so in Deutschland das vielleicht ein bisschen misslungen ist in der letzten Zeit.
Nehmen wir mal so die prägendste Industrie, die Autoindustrie, die ja nun wirklich zum Jagen getragen werden musste,
bis sie dann endlich mal den Wandel hin zu Elektromobilität angeht.
Jetzt wird das, sagen wir mal, so typisch deutsch-industriell auch angegangen.
So nach dem Motto, holla jetzt sind wir aufgewacht, jetzt fangen wir aber auch wirklich an, so.
Nur eben startet man eben sehr weit hinter der Startlinie in gewisser Hinsicht
oder die anderen rennen halt schon und jetzt hat man dann den Schuss auch gehört.
Da ist ja dann was schief gegangen oder?
Also ich meine, da hat das ja dann eigentlich genauso nicht funktioniert, dass der Mensch mitgedacht wurde.
Weil der Mensch wurde nicht mitgedacht, sondern es wurde eigentlich nur die normale wirtschaftliche Logik verfolgt,
so nach dem Motto, ach naja Gott, Verbrennungsmotoren können wir super bauen,
funktioniert, haben wir schon immer so gemacht, das müssen wir jetzt beibehalten als unseren Vorteil,
weil so läuft der Hase, damit verdienen wir halt unsere Brötchen und dieser ganze moderne Kram kostet ja alles nur Geld und will ja auch keiner haben.
Nicht wahr, also das ist ja so ein bisschen diese Marktlogik, die eben nicht von der Innovation so sehr getrieben ist,
sondern eigentlich eher so eine besitzstandswahrende Logik in sich hat.
Auf der einen Seite ja, auf der anderen Seite haben Sie haben ja gesagt, das hat ja nicht wirklich funktioniert,
das stimmt nicht ganz, wenn wir uns die Marktzahlen angucken.
Also die deutschen Automobilunternehmen sind schon in den vergangenen Jahren und Jahrzehnten sehr erfolgreich gewesen.
Also wenn wir einfach nur mal von der Marktseite gucken, würde ich sagen, nicht alles falsch gemacht.
Wenn wir es uns vom Thema, und da kommt jetzt wieder die Ingenieursperspektive rein,
wer macht die besten Autos der Welt, glaube ich, können wir doch noch sagen,
auf vielen Dimensionen sind das die deutschen Automobilbauer.
Warum? Weil sie immer wieder optimiert haben.
Sie haben sehr sehr gut inkremental innoviert.
Wir haben die geringsten Spaltmaße, wir haben die leisesten Verbrennermotoren,
wir haben die effizientesten Verbrennermotoren, wir haben, naja über Schönheit und Design gibt es sicherlich unterschiedliche Auffassungen,
aber auf vielen klassischen Dimensionen sind die deutschen Automobilbauer Weltspitze.
So und damit haben sie durchaus in gewisser Weise nutzerorientiert gearbeitet,
nämlich sie haben sich angeguckt, was wollen denn eigentlich die Leute?
Die wollen schnellere Autos, sie wollen vielleicht dann noch ein bisschen sparsamere Autos,
aber sie wollen große Autos, dicke Autos, wie auch immer, also das haben sie gefragt.
Was sie nie gefragt haben ist, was ist eigentlich Mobilität?
Brauchen wir dafür eigentlich noch Autos?
Sie sind sozusagen nicht, man verwendet immer so gerne diesen Begriff, „thinking outside the box“.
Sie sind nie aus ihrer kleinen Kiste rausgesprungen und haben geguckt,
was gibt es eigentlich noch für Möglichkeiten?
So und dann haben wir einen Fehler gemacht und diesen Fehler sehen wir aber leider in sehr sehr vielen Industrien.
Dass nie von außen mal geguckt wird, sag mal was macht ihr da eigentlich?
Wie produziert ihr eigentlich Energie bzw. wie sieht eigentlich die Zukunft des Energiemarktes aus?
Wie sieht die Zukunft der Mobilität aus?
Wie sieht die Zukunft des Gesundheitswesens aus?
Das können wir in Deutschland nicht, da ist einfach über Jahre,
wir sind Kinder unseres Erfolgs bzw. Opfer unseres Erfolgs.
Der deutschen Volkswirtschaft ging es über Jahrzehnte gut.
Und wenn es uns gut geht, das wissen wir alle, mein Doktorgroßvater Jürgen Hauschild hat mal gesagt,
Innovationen sind im Zweifel nicht willkommen.
Na klar, keiner von uns möchte sich gerne jeden Tag neu verändern, das merken wir jetzt gerade.
Es ist schlimm genug, was da draußen passiert, gib mir ein bisschen Stabilität.
Ich meine, es ist ja, klar, die Momentaufnahme ist, bisher hat es ganz gut funktioniert.
Bloß in dem Moment, wo es dann aufhört zu funktionieren, kann es ja dann auch sehr schnell gehen.
Und was wird jetzt eben debattiert mit großen Entlassungszahlen, die VW vielleicht anstehen,
weil man halt merkt, naja okay, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie Elektroautos bauen,
holla, dann müssen wir ja auf einmal ganz viele Dinge gar nicht mehr bauen.
Wir brauchen irgendwie keine Einspritzer und die entsprechende Filtertechnik und ganz viele Bauteile fallen auf einmal weg
und damit natürlich ganz viele Subindustrien und der Schock ist natürlich immer sehr viel größer,
wenn das eben so von heute auf morgen geschieht, weil es natürlich dann noch mal sehr viel mehr Widerstände gibt etc..
Man findet sich dann eben an so einem Punkt wieder, wo man dann doch in der Abrechnung zu viel Zeit hat verstreichen lassen,
weil man sich eben gegen diese Innovation gesperrt hat.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt die eigentliche Frage, was können denn Unternehmen an sich dagegen tun,
um in diese Falle nicht zu tappen.
Das ist ja immer so dieses, gibt jetzt tausend Zitate, die immer so im Raum rumgestoßen werden,
wo man nie genau weiß, ob die so eigentlich gefallen sind, aber trotzdem beschreiben Sie, glaube ich, das ganz gut.
Also als das Automobil kam so, war es halt so die schnelleren Pferde, die alle haben wollten.
Und so mit diesen tolleren Autos ist es halt auch so ein bisschen wie mit diesen schnelleren Pferden.
Die Leute denken halt dann auch irgendwie so, ach ja ich hatte bisher ein Auto, also brauche ich jetzt wieder ein Auto
und das muss irgendwas besser daran sein, nur dass irgendwie keinem so recht was einfallen kann,
was überhaupt noch besser ist, man aber eben sehr viel annimmt für dieses Produkt,
wo die Gesellschaft eigentlich schon einen Schritt weiter ist, dass sie sagt, wir wollen aber jetzt nicht mehr so viel Platz in den Städten den Autos opfern
und das macht uns irgendwie auch krank und es nimmt uns irgendwie auch sozialen Raum,
gerade jetzt in der Pandemie ist so dieses soziale Kontakte irgendwie, merkt man jetzt sozusagen überhaupt erst mal,
glaube ich, diese Bedeutung dessen noch mal mehr und die Städte müssen sich wandeln und die Städte wollen sich langsam auch wandeln.
Und ich denke, dass schon dieser Industriebereich jetzt an so einem Punkt steht, dass wenn jetzt nicht sehr schnell gehandelt wird,
viel von dem bisher erreichten dann so ein Pyrrhussieg ist, dass man halt einfach sieht,
da haben wir uns einfach falsch entwickelt.
Naja, das ist natürlich die zentrale Frage, die Sie da gerade stellen.
Also wie bringen wir die Wirtschaft, aber auch die Gesellschaft letztendlich, dazu, frühzeitiger innovativ zu sein?
Also die Historie der Innovationsforschung zeigt uns, wir haben diese sogenannten Kondratieff-Zyklen
und immer, wenn es uns richtig schlecht ging, dann kamen die Innovationen.
Dann kam die erste industrielle Revolution und die zweite und die dritte so.
Und es scheint historisch gesehen so zu sein, es muss uns erst richtig schlecht gehen,
es muss uns richtig weh tun, weil erst dann wir bereit sind, Verhaltensänderungen anzustreben.
So, eigentlich haben wir jetzt gerade den Punkt, Thema Klimawandel, eigentlich geht es uns richtig schlecht,
nur so richtig spüren wir es noch nicht.
Und dann stellt sich die Frage, wer hat jetzt die Verantwortung, diese Impulse zu setzen?
Und da kommen wir dann schon wieder auf diese Diskussionsebene,
schafft der Markt, schaffen es die Unternehmen von sich aus, sich zu verändern
und neue Impulse zu setzen oder brauchen wir den Staat, die Politik, um entsprechende Impulse zu setzen?
Wo sich dann sehr schnell die Frage anschließt, kann der Staat tatsächlich innovativer sein als die Unternehmen oder als die Gesellschaft?
Sie sprachen das gerade an, die Bürgerinnen und Bürger spüren, irgendwie so richtig cool fühlt sich das nicht mehr an.
Aber schaffen sie es als Gesellschaft, diese Impulse zu setzen oder einzufordern
oder ist das dann doch wieder zu anstrengend oder wir wissen ja nicht genau, welche Impulse es jetzt sein sollen.
Ist ja immer so ein bisschen dieses Element der Disruption.
Also die großen Gewinner der letzten Jahrzehnte, das gilt natürlich vor allem jetzt im digitalen Internetbereich,
Google, Facebook etc. sind halt reingegangen und haben den Status quo dahingehen infrage gestellt,
als dass sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen irgendwie was ganz anderes und wir sind jetzt hier die Disruptoren
oder wie das irgendwie Tesla im Automobilbereich gemacht hat und einfach Dinge generell infrage gestellt hat.
Einfach andere Vertriebsstrukturen, andere technische Möglichkeiten.
Und Unternehmen, denen es über einen längeren Zeitraum gelingt, sich nicht durch die nächste Disruptionswelle den Teppich unter den Füßen wegziehen zu lassen,
könnte man zum Beispiel mal auf Apple schauen, die sich ja nun wirklich schon bemerkenswert lange halten
und dabei eigentlich auch immer so vorgegangen sind, dass sie so ihr eigener Feind sind.
Dass sie einfach immer über sich selber so nachdenken, so, oh jetzt sind wir hier Platzhirsch,
wie können wir uns selber den Platz streitig machen?
Und darüber sozusagen so einen Innovationsdruck auf sich selbst erlegen,
indem man sich eben selbst als Feind sieht.
Das ist aber so eine Denkweise, die ich jetzt so im europäischen oder vielleicht auch konkret im deutschen Denken, Wirtschaftsdenken so nicht fühle.
Richtig.
Also das ist das, wir nennen das in der Innovationsforschung immer den Fluch der etablierten Unternehmen.
Und das sehen wir in Deutschland sehr stark.
Also dieser Wille, sich selber infrage zu stellen, der Wille, Dinge auszuprobieren,
von denen wir noch nicht wissen, ob sie uns tatsächlich Geld bringen werden,
wir sind in vielen Bereichen sehr, konservativ ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber sehr formalistisch organisiert und strukturiert.
Und das finden wir in den Unternehmen auch.
Da wird dann immer gleich nach dem Return on Investment gefragt.
Da wird gefragt, wird es uns Geld bringen?
Da werden diejenigen, die etwas ausprobieren und womöglich 100.000 Euro oder womöglich eine Million in den Sand setzen,
geteert und gefedert und vom Hof gejagt, da werden diejenigen, die sagen,
also hier der Farbfilm ist es nicht mehr, es ist in Zukunft die Digitalfotografie,
da wird auch gesagt, vielen Dank Ablage F.
Das hat viel für mich mit dieser deutschen Einstellung zu tun.
Im Positiven haben wir es geschafft, ich hatte es gerade schon erwähnt, diese inkrementellen Innovationen.
Und immer noch mal ein bisschen besser werden.
Und schauen wir uns um, wir haben eine unglaublich stabile Gesellschaft bisher,
im Moment fragen wir uns alle so ein bisschen was passiert, aber grundsätzlich klagen auf sehr hohem Niveau.
Also grundsätzlich funktioniert alles.
Das kommt dadurch, dass wir dieses, ich nenne das immer Kästchendenken, wir können prima in Kästchen denken,
aber für disruptive Innovation, für diese Herausforderungen, vor denen wir jetzt stehen,
müssen wir außerhalb dieser Kästchen denken.
Und das ist aber eine Denk- und Lebensweise, die müssen wir alle lernen.
Denn wie gesagt das tut erst mal weh, weil ich meinen eigenen Anspruch, mein eigenes Machtbewusstsein,
mein eigenes, das habe ich mir aber verdient, das muss ich aufgeben und muss mich mit einer Unsicherheit anfreunden,
von der ich heute nicht weiß, was sie mir morgen bringt.
Die Automobilunternehmen, um noch mal das Beispiel versuchen fortzuführen,
haben ja aber auch teilweise das ja auch probiert.
Also sie haben Car Sharing Projekte gehabt und was weiß ich, BMW hat schon sehr früh ein Elektrofahrzeug auf den Weg gebracht,
wo man so gedacht hat, ah okay, das könnte ja was werden.
Und auch teilweise solche Innovationsmodelle mit so ausgelagerten Unternehmen gehabt,
die dann so vor sich hinwurschteln können, außerhalb der normalen Konzernstruktur,
schon so ein bisschen mit diesem Versuch, ja versucht uns mal Konkurrenz zu machen
und wir gucken mal, was dabei rauskommt.
Aber offensichtlich scheint das ja nicht gereicht zu haben.
Was machen die denn da falsch?
Also werden da die Lehren nicht richtig gewonnen oder werden die Lehren, die dann gezogen wurden, ignoriert?
Was fehlt denn in diesem Innovationskranz sozusagen an angezündeten Kerzen,
um da diesen Prozess auch wirklich so umzusetzen?
Ich bin keine tiefe Kennerin der Automobilindustrie.
Ich habe immer mal wieder Projekte mit denen zusammen macht,
und insofern würde ich mich jetzt mal versuchen an einer Interpretation.
Ich glaube, das was versucht wurde das hatten Sie sehr schön beschrieben,
es gibt immer mal so die eine oder andere, so ein kleines Experimentallabor,
so jetzt dürft ihr mal ausprobieren, aber das, wonach diese Unternehmen ticken
und so wie sie aufgestellt sind, das ist immer der größere Motor, das größere Auto.
Das breitere Auto, mehr Technik, mehr Elektronik, das ist sehr technikgetrieben.
Das heißt, die Gelder gingen immer in die Neuentwicklung, beispielsweise in die S-Klasse oder in jetzt den neuen SUV.
Das heißt, es waren immer eigentlich diese alten Geschichten.
Und die anderen, das war immer so ein bisschen, jetzt probiert euch mal aus,
aber ganz ehrlich, so richtig viel Geld werden wir damit nicht verdienen.
Und dementsprechend waren natürlich auch nicht die Ressourcen dahinter
und es wurde dann nicht in den Markt richtig geschubst und gestoßen
und es wurde versucht, tatsächlich so ein Umdenken anzustreben.
Denn auch klar, mit Drive Now, natürlich hat Daimler das probiert,
aber es war immer klar, wir machen uns hier eigentlich unser eigenes Geschäft kaputt,
also seid bloß vorsichtig was ihr macht.
So das heißt, die internen Leistungskennzahlen, wie machen Sie Karriere in so einem Unternehmen?
Wie bekommen Sie Ruhm und Ehre, das sind immer noch die klassischen.
Und dementsprechend orientieren sich die Menschen natürlich auch in so einem Unternehmen.
Und das gilt nicht nur für die Automobilindustrie, das sehen wir in allen Unternehmen.
Es sind sehr traditionelle Entwicklungsperspektiven, Vergütungsstrukturen,
es sind dann immer wieder die Punkte, wo gesagt wird, ja aber diesen Weg bin ich doch auch gegangen
und das müssen die anderen auch so machen.
Und das ist für Innovation total schädlich.
Und jetzt ich sehe das ja, ich unterhalte mich häufig mit Unternehmensvertretern, so dieses,
ja jetzt die junge Generation und die wollen ja alle nicht mehr so viel arbeiten
und die wollen nur noch 30 Stunden und dann wollen sie aber hier noch was verdienen,
da stoßen Welten aufeinander und das ist im Moment sehr spannend als Innovationsforscherin zu beobachten,
was passiert da eigentlich in den Unternehmen?
Schaffen wir es mit diesen jungen Leuten, die wirklich anders herangehen,
die gehen anders an das Thema Arbeiten heran, die sind digitalisiert,
die haben nicht mehr diese Statussymbole, es muss mindestens ein Auto, wenn nicht zwei Autos vor der Tür sein.
Gleichzeitig spüren die eine ganz große Unsicherheit, die wissen nicht, wo sie in 20 Jahren sein werden.
Und das ist jetzt die Frage, schaffen die Unternehmen es, sich so zu öffnen, so zu wandeln,
dass sie diese Impulse aufnehmen und dann könnten sie innovativ sein.
Aber ich sehe unglaubliche Beharrungstendenzen.
Wenn so dieses, wir verdienen da ja kein Geld mit, wenn das sozusagen die Leistungskennzahl ist,
die einzige, und das funktioniert nicht, was wäre denn eine andere Leistungskennzahl,
an der man diese Aktivitäten bewerten kann, ohne jetzt einfach nur an das Bauchgefühl zu appellieren?
Kann man den Menschen, ich meine, ich kann die ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch verstehen,
wenn die da in so einer mittleren Organisationsstruktur sind, oben der dicke Konzern,
ja, der immer nur das große Ganze sieht, das muss irgendwie alles funktionieren,
dann sind die da so in diesem Bereich, haben irgendwie größere Teile unter sich,
was sollen sie denn anderes bewerten als, man kann dasselbe günstiger machen oder wir bauen irgendwas,
wo wir es den Kunden noch ein geredet bekommen.
Also diese Eigendisruption muss ja dann auch in irgendeiner Form bewertet werden können,
was wäre denn so eine Leistungskennzahl?
Ja, also am Ende müssen natürlich die Umsätze stimmen, das ist klar,
sonst kann ich meine ArbeitnehmerInnen nicht bezahlen.
Ja, klar.
Also damit bin ich raus.
Aber das, was ich mir wünschen würde, wäre dass die Betrachtungszeiträume etwas gestreckt werden,
dass gesagt wird, also es muss nicht, ähnlich wie wir ja auch Startup-Unternehmen betrachten,
die sind in den ersten drei bis fünf Jahren nicht positiv im Cashflow.
So und genauso solche Zeit muss ich disruptiven Innovationen im Unternehmen auch geben.
In diesem Zeit gibt es dann sehr wohl Leistungskennzahlen, wo ich gucken kann,
haben sie entsprechend so und so viel neue Kunden akquiriert, ist die Technologie, das Produkt, die Dienstleistung, ist das eingesetzt worden?
Habe ich entsprechend, also bei den Innovationskennzahlen kann ich ja einerseits mir produktspezifische Kennzahlen angucken,
dienstleistungsspezifische Kennzahlen, so wie ich sie gerade zitiert habe,
aber ich kann ja auch gucken, habe ich einen Impact in der Gesellschaft gehabt?
Hat sich da etwas verändert, hat sich da eine Denkweise verändert?
Ich kann mir ökologische Kennzahlen angucken.
Habe ich es geschafft, meine Produktionslinie entsprechend effizienter zu machen,
dass ich weniger Wasser verbrauche, dass ich weniger Strom verbrauche.
Also da sind wir auch, dieses Thema Innovationscontrolling ist kein einfaches,
muss auch jedes Unternehmen für sich selber entscheiden, was sind da Kennzahlen, mit denen wir arbeiten können,
wichtig ist es nur, den Mut zu haben zu sagen, wir werden da erst mal sehr wahrscheinlich sogar relativ viel Geld reinstecken müssen.
Das Ganze trägt sich ja jetzt dann zwangsläufig in die Gesellschaft und damit natürlich auch in die Politik, so.
Also wenn wir jetzt sagen, die wirtschaftlichen Leistungskennzahlen die sind schwierig zu greifen,
weil am Ende geht es dann doch immer irgendwie um Geld, wir müssen aber jetzt trotzdem noch andere Größenordnungen mit reinnehmen
und dann ist ja auch irgendwie die Gesellschaft gefragt und damit ja quasi auch so die Kunden und was wollen die eigentlich und so weiter,
aber auch was will die Politik.
Sprich, jetzt müssen wir eigentlich für die Gesamtwirtschaft oder für die Gesamtgesellschaft,
wo die Wirtschaft ein Teil davon ist, eben diese gesellschaftlichen Leistungskennzahlen,
so würde ich es jetzt mal nennen, auch mit definieren und das geschieht ja teilweise dann eben auch durch die politischen Vorgaben.
Wobei man jetzt so ein bisschen den Eindruck gewonnen hat, dass die Politik halt mehr oder weniger eigentlich immer dem gefolgt ist,
was die Wirtschaft gesagt hat.
Die Wirtschaft sagt, da verdienen wir kein Geld damit, dann sagt die Politik,
naja, wenn das so ist, dann machen wir da halt mal lieber nichts.
Das ist so ein bisschen, glaube ich, so ein Missverständnis, was sich so in den letzten Jahren so durchgesetzt hat.
Jetzt sind Sie ja auch Teil so einer Beratungsoffensive, sage ich mal,
also da gibt es einerseits diese Expertenkommission Forschung und Innovation,
die der Bundesregierung zuarbeitet und es gibt auch noch ein Hightech-Forum,
auch der Bundesregierung, was sind das so für Kommissionen, wie sind die aufgestellt, was sollen die eigentlich tun?
Die Expertenkommission Forschung und Innovation ist vor gut zehn Jahren,
vor elf Jahren ins Leben gerufen worden als innovationsökonomische Kommission,
die genau solche Fragen, wie wir sie jetzt gerade diskutieren und Sie so schön anmoderiert haben,
dabei Hilfestellung leisten soll, indem sie, wir machen das einmal jährlich in einem Gutachten,
und wir machen es auch mittlerweile unterjährig über sogenannte Policy Briefs,
wo wir dann so auf zwei, drei Seiten zu einem Thema Stellung nehmen.
Wir sind sechs Wissenschaftler, Wissenschaftlerinnen, drei, drei, die aus dem Bereich der Innovationsökonomie kommen,
also eher volkswirtschaftlich orientiert bzw. die Kollegin Häusler und ich eben aus dem Bereich Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen,
und die der Politik sagen, also aus wissenschaftlicher Perspektive, das, was die Wissenschaft heute herausgefunden hat,
also wirklich aktuelle Forschungsergebnisse, würden wir euch folgendes empfehlen.
Und wir versuchen, das Ganze sowohl empirisch zu begründen, indem wir regelmäßig Befragungen dazu durchführen
bzw. diese dann auswerten oder das Ganze auch durchaus mal mit einem theoretischen Modell begründen
und sagen, pass mal auf, die Theorie sagt, der Markt würde sich folgendermaßen verhalten.
Wenn ihr als Politik jetzt das entscheidet, dann gibt es folgende Möglichkeiten.
Und da hören wir dann auf.
Wir versuchen, Theorie und empirisch gestützte Empfehlungen abzugeben,
zu sagen, also wenn ihr uns fragen würdet, was ihr ja tut, sonst wären wir nicht eingesetzt,
dann sind das unsere Empfehlungen, was ihr damit macht, ist natürlich euch überlassen.
Wie oft findet das statt?
Es gibt einmal im Jahr das EFI-Gutachten.
Wir schreiben gerade das Gutachten, was im Februar 2022 übergeben werden,
bisher haben wir es immer direkt an Frau Merkel übergeben.
Wir hoffen sehr, dass wir im Februar 2022 das an Herrn Scholz übergeben dürfen,
gleichzeitig sind wir eben sehr eng mit dem Bundesbildungs- und Forschungsministerium, dem BMBF, im Austausch,
aber wie gesagt, wir sind kein Gremium des BMBF, sondern tatsächlich eingesetzt durch den deutschen Bundestag.
Also das heißt, unsere Adressaten sind die ParlamentarierInnen aber auch die Gesellschaft und die Wirtschaft.
Das heißt, unser Gutachten ist sehr bewusst so geschrieben, dass wir versuchen,
diese wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse so aufzubereiten, dass es einer möglichst breiten Öffentlichkeit zugänglich ist.
Und das ist nicht einfach, da können wir uns auch wunderbar drüber streiten im Kreise der Experten,
aber das ist der Anspruch und das sind dann solche Themen wie, die Agilität des Staates beispielsweise im letzten Jahr.
Wir haben im letzten Jahr zu CRISPR/Cas Stellung genommen,
was bedeutet das, wie sollte sich Deutschland da aufstellen.
Also die Genschere.
Die Genschere genau.
Wir haben auch zu Blockchain schon mal was geschrieben, wir haben natürlich schon mal was zum Thema Digitalisierung in Gesellschaft,
in der Bildung geschrieben, wir haben schon mal was zum Thema, also breite Themenvielfalt.
Arbeitsmarkt der Zukunft letztes Jahr.
Ja. Ich greife mal eins raus, Agilität des Staates, das ist ja, sagen wir mal, klingt so ein bisschen wie ein Widerspruch in sich.
/lacht/
Was steht denn da drin?
Also was wird denn dann so dem Staat vorgeschlagen?
Und anhand welcher Forschungsergebnisse macht man das dann fest?
Genau, das war also Kapitel im letzten Jahr, was eben momentan hochaktuell ist.
Wir haben dann auch tatsächlich noch mal zwei Policy Briefs darauf aufbauend geschrieben.
Wir haben ja auch beispielsweise ein Ministerium neuen Zuschnitts gefordert vor einigen Monaten,
das könnte ein Digitalministerium sein, es hätte aber auch jedes andere Ministerium sein können.
In dem wir eben genau das gefordert haben, die Politik, der Staat muss agiler werden.
Was heißt agiler?
Agiler heißt, dass er schneller reagiert, dass er Dinge ausprobiert, sie dann auch gerne,
wenn er feststellt, das funktioniert so nicht, wieder sein lässt und iterativ auf den Erfahrungen aufbaut und dann weiterdenkt.
Also das ist sozusagen dieser Grundbegriff der Agilität.
Und Sie sagten gerade schon so schön, das ist doch ein Widerspruch in sich, ist es tatsächlich.
Aktuell, wenn wir uns den deutschen Staat angucken, kann sich kaum jemand vorstellen, dass dieser Staat agil ist.
Wenn wir uns aber die großen gesellschaftlichen Herausforderungen angucken,
dann müssen wir das, denn keiner von uns weiß, wie wir die Klimakrise lösen, das weiß keiner.
Das einzige, was wir machen können, ist, und da kommt jetzt, und das war ein zweiter wichtiger Teil in diesem Kapitel,
ist diese Missionsorientierung.
Der Staat kann sogenannte Missionen vorgeben und sagen, wir gehen aktiv die Klimakrise an,
indem wir beispielsweise, Thema Kennzahl, die Erwärmung auf 1,5 Grad begrenzen
und wir machen das mit folgenden Maßnahmen.
So damit gibt der Staat einen Rahmen vor.
Wie wir diesen Rahmen jetzt ausmalen und das Bild ist auch schon skizziert,
aber welche Farben wir dafür nutzen, wie wir das ausmalen, ob wir das jetzt mit Pastellfarben machen,
Aquarellfarben oder Ölfarben oder ob wir dieses Bild noch mal anpassen müssen,
das ist dann wiederum vielen Akteuren überlassen und das ist uns eben ganz wichtig,
der Staat kann nicht alles machen.
Und da haben wir schon auch wieder dieses Thema Agilität bzw. warum wir dann als EFI mit dem Thema innovationsökonomischem Sachverstand sagen,
der Staat hat eine wichtige Rolle zu spielen, aber anders beispielsweise als Mariana Mazzucato,
die sagt, der Staat geht dann ins kleinste Detail und gibt dann vor, in Zukunft nur noch Elektromobilität.
Sagen wir eben, es muss in diesem Rahmen muss es Flexibilität geben.
Das mit den Pastellfarben steht da bestimmt so nicht drin.
Nein, das habe ich jetzt gerade für Sie.
Ja, ja, ich habe nichts gegen Bilder, aber mich interessiert wirklich auch mal, was steht denn konkret drin?
Ich habe es natürlich nicht gelesen, ich fauler Sack, aber was…
Weil worauf ich ein bisschen hinaus will, ist, wenn man sich über Innovation und Effektivität von Maßnahmen und so weiter Gedanken macht,
dann macht man sich ja wahrscheinlich auch Gedanken darüber, was schreibe ich jetzt in so ein Paper rein,
und was bewirkt es einfach auch mal konkret.
Also man muss ja sozusagen auch diese konkrete Schnittstelle zu einer Bundesregierung oder einem Bundesministerium
auch so denken, so nach dem Motto, okay wir haben jetzt hier einen begrenzten Zeitraum,
wir machen jetzt hier eine Empfehlung, was schreiben wir da rein und wie schreiben wir das da rein,
damit das dann auch in gewisser Hinsicht Erfolg haben kann.
Das ist ein ganz dünner Grat, weil wir nicht die Politik machen wollen und auch können, dafür sind wir nicht ausgebildet.
Ja klar.
Das heißt, wir werden der Politik nie sagen, mach A, mach B, mach C,
sondern auch da sagen wir nur, wir empfehlen beispielsweise, eine missionsorientierte Politik zu betreiben.
Was beutetet missionsorientiert?
Ich hatte das gerade eben kurz angesprochen.
So das könnte beispielsweise, Sie haben ja das Hightech-Forum schon angesprochen,
das könnte im Rahmen der Hightech-Strategie erfolgen.
Die Hightech-Strategie, die wir in den vergangen vier Jahren hatten, war eine quasi missionsorientierte Politik.
Da wurden also auch Dekade des Krebses, also wir als Bundesregierung geben vor,
wir wollen das Thema Krebsforschung ganz stark vorantreiben.
Wie sieht es dann ganz konkret aus?
Das müssen dann die Akutere übersetzen.
Und da kommt dann beispielsweise jetzt das Hightech-Forum rein, das im Vergleich zur EFI-Kommission sehr viel pragmatischer arbeitet.
Da sind Vertreter aus der Wirtschaft dabei, da sind Unternehmer dabei, Unternehmerinnen,
Startup-Unternehmerinnen, Mittelständler, Großunternehmer bzw. eben aus dem Management.
Da ist die Wissenschaft dabei, verschiedene Forschungsinstitute, da ist die Gesellschaft dabei,
nicht so stark wie wir es uns gewünscht hätten, das gibt es vielleicht jetzt in der nächsten Iteration.
Denn das und das beantwortet jetzt Ihre Frage, wer bestimmt das jetzt eigentlich und wer macht das eigentlich jetzt,
das müssen die gesellschaftlichen Akteure sein.
Das muss dann die Wissenschaft, die Wirtschaft, die Politik und die Gesellschaft, das sind ja diese vier Stränge,
die müssen das gemeinsam in einem Diskurs ausdiskutieren und sagen,
was bedeutet diese Mission jetzt, Dekade des Krebses?
Reduktion der globalen Erwärmung um 1,5 Grad, was sind meine Antworten als Wissenschaftler,
als Gesellschaft, als Wirtschaft, was sind meine Antworten darauf und wo können wir da zusammenarbeiten?
Und die Politik ist für mich oder dann eben auch für uns als EFI und im Hightech-Forum ist es ähnlich, ein Moderator, ein Rahmengeber.
Im letzten Gespräch hier bei Forschergeist habe ich mich mal mit Rafael Laguna de la Vera unterhalten,
der ja dieses neue Institut für Sprunginnovationen vornimmt, das ist ja dann sozusagen auch so eine Manifestation dieser Idee,
Innovationen auch wirklich als Teil des Staates zu machen, haben Sie da auch Kontakt?
Ist das Teil Ihrer Forschung?
Ja, natürlich. Also auf der einen Seite ist die Agentur für Sprunginnovation ja quasi ein EFI-Produkt,
also die EFI hat unter der Leitung von Dietmar Harhoff über Jahre gefordert,
dass es eine solche Agentur braucht oder eine solche Institution, die eben frei von politischen Vorgaben Geld in die Hand nehmen kann,
um einfach mal diese verrückten Ideen, an die nämlich sonst keiner glaubt,
für die es noch keine Kennzahlen gibt, für die wir im Zweifel noch gar nicht wissen, wer es eigentlich machen soll,
so etwas anstoßen kann.
Also insofern ist die EFI und die SPRIND die sind sehr eng miteinander vertraut, sage ich mal so.
Davon abgesehen, dass eben dann wir uns auch immer versuchen abzugleichen, wer macht eigentlich gerade was
oder wir versuchen uns da auch entsprechend auszutauschen.
Jetzt habe ich Ihre Frage vergessen.
Ja, das war die Frage, also wie hängt das zusammen?
Also haben Sie ja im Prinzip schon gesagt, dass ist ein Ergebnis sozusagen oder war zumindest mal ein Vorschlag.
Ja, genau.
Und das kam bei raus, kann man jetzt sagen, okay das ist nur weil wir das gesagt haben, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und andere Akteure, ja genau, das will ich jetzt gar nicht …
Und das sind sozusagen Ziele und damit auch messbare Ergebnisse.
Ich meine, inwiefern die Ergebnisse dieser Agentur messbar sind, das werden wir dann erst noch sehen,
Aber ist ja zumindest schon mal ein Gedanke gewesen, so nach dem Motto, wir brauchen so was ähnliches eben wie die DARPA in den USA.
Also eine Institution, die eben konkret auch was auslösen kann, indem sie auch wirklich mal konkret Geld in die Hand nehmen kann
und unabhängig von dem eigentlichen politischen Vorgang, der zwangsläufig langsam ist,
weil er immer versucht, einen politischen Konsens auszuhandeln, einfach mal Dinge ausprobiert und Kohle verbraten kann
und dann auch mal in Kauf nimmt, dass irgendwas nicht so gut funktioniert,
weil wenn man genug Sachen nimmt, irgendwas wird eben schon hängenbleiben.
Aber mich interessiert halt jetzt wirklich dieses, vielleicht gibt es noch ein paar Sachen,
die man dazu sagen kann, so dieses Interface von der Wissenschaft zur Politik.
Weil ich stelle mir halt immer so ein bisschen vor, naja Gutachter, Kommission, Gremien, alles schön und gut,
da macht man dann mal so sein Papierchen, das legt man hin, dann hat man eine Presskonferenz
und dann wird einem schön gedankt, wie innovativ das doch jetzt wieder alles ist und dann ist nächsten Montag wieder business as usual.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen vielleicht auch, ne…
Wie das dann wahrgenommen wird, manchmal findet es wahrscheinlich auch so statt,
aber haben Sie auch das Gefühl, dass das so ist oder ist es anders?
Wie verfängt das?
Also wie Ofen ist der politische Prozess für die wissenschaftliche Beratung konkret?
Also die Frage stellen wir uns ja selber auch immer wieder.
Das Hightech-Forum ist ja jetzt geendet mit der letzten Legislaturperiode.
Ob es das wieder geben wird, ob es eine Hightech-Strategie, sie ist ja zumindest im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten,
oder eine Zukunftsstrategie geben wird, wer die begleiten wird, das werden wir sehen.
Ich sehe den Einfluss oder wir nennen das neudeutsch ja immer so schön Impact auf verschiedenen Dimensionen.
Also wenn ich jetzt noch mal für die EFI spreche, wir glauben und das, was wir an Feedback bekommen,
gelingt es uns, mit unseren Gutachten immer wieder aktuelle Themen aufzugreifen,
sie zu übersetzen für die Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier, ihnen zu zeigen,
wo da beispielsweise Innovation drinsteckt, also jetzt wieder Beispiel Genschere CRISPR/Cas,
wie Politik gestaltet werden sollte, Thema agiler Staat oder Arbeitsmarkt der Zukunft,
was sind eigentlich die Fähigkeiten, die die Arbeitnehmerinnen in Zukunft brauchen werden.
Das sind Impulse, die wir setzen, die werden gelesen, die werden reflektiert,
die werden in den Ausschüssen diskutiert, das wissen wir.
Wir wissen auch, dass sie in den Ministerien aufgegriffen werden
und da teilweise nach einigen Jahren, also das mussten wir schon lernen,
dass dieses Brett doch ein bisschen dicker ist, aber wenn man immer wieder da auch reinbohrt
und wir greifen auch Themen immer wieder auf, dass wir sagen, im letzten Jahr haben wir
und es ist immer noch nichts passiert und jetzt macht doch bitte mal was,
3,5 Prozent Ziel für die Innovationsausgaben ist so eine andere EFI-Forderung,
die also auch sehr lange immer wieder wiederholt werden musste, bis sie dann umgesetzt wurde.
Was ich persönlich lernen musste ist, dass Politik unglaublich vielfältig ist,
das, was in den Ministerien passiert und das, was im Bundestag passiert,
das ist so das eine, was wir beeinflussen können als Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler.
Das, was dann nachher in der konkreten Politikarbeit dann tatsächlich Eingang in Gesetzesvorhaben
oder Umsetzungsprojekte findet, das ist dann wiederum und da haben wir schon letztendlich eine Vergleichbarkeit mit den großen Unternehmen,
das ist dann wieder von sehr vielen Partikularinteressen getrieben.
Es ist dann der einzelne Parlamentarier, der jetzt vor Ort seinem Wahlkreis etwas gutes tun will.
Und plötzlich sind die schönsten Konzepte werden also wieder infrage gestellt,
weil gesagt wird, naja das müssen wir jetzt noch mal überdenken.
Also mein Gefühl ist, dass wir die richtigen Impulse setzen, dass wir objektive Fakten liefern können.
Wir bemühen uns, objektiv abgeleitete Handlungsempfehlungen zu geben,
den Wissensraum der Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier zu öffnen,
die Ministerien mit einer weiteren Meinung zu versehen, bereitzustellen,
natürlich auch entsprechend bei Diskussionen Rückfragen Kommissionssitzungen zur Verfügung zu stellen,
aber auf die endgültige Entscheidung, was dann nachher umgesetzt wird, haben wir tatsächlich relativ wenig Einfluss.
Ja gut, ich meine, auch das ist ja ein Experiment, was man beobachten kann.
Man sieht ja, okay diese Aktivität hat folgende Ergebnisse erzielt und hier war es jetzt nicht so erfolgreich,
das kann man ja wie so ein kleines Laborexperiment im Prinzip betrachten, daraus so seine Schlussfolgerungen ziehen so.
Und was mich noch mal interessieren würde, was glauben Sie oder was ist so Ihr Gefühl,
wo es denn am meisten verfängt?
Weil Sie meinten ja, es gibt im Prinzip mehrere Adressaten, auf der einen Seite ist es so der Bundestag, die Parlamentarier,
gut die wechseln dann alle paar Jahre, jetzt mischt sich der Reigen wieder komplett neu,
da geht natürlich dann auch viel verloren in gewisser Hinsicht, weil all die Leute, mit denen man gesprochen hat,
sind ja dann weg, kann aber auch ein Vorteil sein.
Das gleiche gilt natürlich jetzt auch für die Bundesregierung, wobei die Leute, die dort mitmachen,
wahrscheinlich schon auch vorher eine Weile dabei waren, das sind ja jetzt nicht die kompletten Novizen mit wenigen Ausnahmen.
Aber dann gibt es ja auch noch so andere Bereiche.
Also erst mal die Ministerien, die tauschen ihren Apparat ja jetzt nicht aus,
sondern da hat man ja auch über längere Zeit Ansprechpartner und dann gibt es ja auch noch so Gruppen wie den wissenschaftlichen Dienst,
wo ja ohnehin so eine permanente wissenschaftliche Dienstleistung, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, geleistet wird.
Wenn man sich also dieses Spektrum jetzt anschaut und jetzt vielleicht mal den Blick zurückwirft
und jetzt mal als Adressat dieser Aussage die Wissenschaft in Deutschland nimmt und sagt,
okay, hör mal, das ist der Einfluss, den ihr nehmen könnt, wie müsste sich quasi die Wissenschaft ausrichten?
Wo macht vielleicht auch die Wissenschaft derzeit noch einen Fehler oder hat Optimierungspotenzial,
um es mal etwas vorsichtiger auszudrücken, in die Gesellschaft in Form der Politik Einfluss zu nehmen?
Eine vielfältige Frage.
Ich fange noch mal kurz mit einer Reflexion an, es gibt nämlich noch einen Punkt, den ich gerade vergessen habe,
der führt uns dann aber zu dem nächsten.
Ich musste die Erfahrung machen, dass ich sehr viel geduldiger werden musste im Kontext der Wissens- oder Politikberatung.
Ich habe mehrere Runden, also gerade jetzt dieses Thema Verwaltungsinnovationen, agiler Staat,
das war natürlich im letzten Jahr vor der Bundestagswahl war das ein ganz heißes Thema.
Und es gab unglaublich viele Gesprächsrunden und Diskussionsrunden.
Und ich erinnere mich an eine Runde, da hatte Herr Scholz eingeladen zehn Wissenschaftskollegen und -kolleginnen
und da sollte es also wieder um Verwaltungsinnovation und den modernen Staat gehen.
Und wir haben dann angefangen und ich hatte begeistert ja gesagt, weil ich mir dachte,
naja das ist jetzt endlich mal der richtige Rahmen und ganz viele BMWI und BMBF und BMI,
also Innenministerium und Wirtschaft, alle waren sie dabei.
Und dann kamen wieder dieselben Fragen und es kamen wieder dieselben Antworten.
Und das war also diese Eingangsrunde und ich beendete dann den Reigen dann.
Welche Fragen und welche Antworten?
Na die Frage, was müssen wir denn tun, um den Staat zu modernisieren?
Wie können wir den Staat agiler machen?
Wie muss eine Innovationsorientierte Politik aussehen?
Also die Fragen, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben.
Und das waren Fragen, die hatte ich in den vergangenen Monaten fünf-, zehnmal gehört, adressiert.
So und die kamen hier wieder und die Kollegen aus den Verwaltungswissenschaften, aus der Innovationsforschung,
aus der Ökonomie, das waren so eigentlich die drei, haben das gefühlt immer wieder dasselbe gesagt.
Und es brach tatsächlich emotional aus mir heraus, dass ich sagte, Herr Scholz Sie hören das jetzt zum zehnten Mal,
warum fragen Sie uns immer wieder dieselben Fragen?
Das kann doch nicht sein, warum müssen wir das immer wiederholen?
So und dann wurde ich also belehrt, sowohl auch von meinen Kollegen, als dann eben auch,
Herr Scholz hat sich da etwas zurückgehalten, aber von den anwesenden Ministerialvertretern,
ja so einfach ist das ja nicht.
Und da sind wir wieder bei diesem Thema Veränderungsresistenz.
Und dann wurde ich darüber aufgeklärt, dass die moderne Verwaltung sich eben nicht von heute auf morgen verändern kann.
Und dass sie nicht von heute auf morgen ein Experimentallabor machen kann.
Und dass sie nicht von heute auf morgen mal eben agil sein kann.
Und das war für mich aber ein ganz wichtiger Moment, weil ich festgestellt habe,
genau die Frage, die Sie gerade gestellt haben, was für einen Einfluss habe ich denn eigentlich,
wenn ich mir immer wieder den Mund fusselig rede.
So und die Frage habe ich auch immer noch nicht für mich beantwortet,
außer dass ich eben denke, steter Tropfen höhlt den Stein und immer wieder bohren
und irgendwann haben wir das Brett geschafft.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, und ich habe aber dadurch festgestellt und jetzt komme ich auf Ihre Frage,
was müssen wir als Wissenschaft anders machen, was müssen wir besser machen?
Wir müssen immer wieder das, was wir erforschen, das, was wir herausfinden, müssen wir spiegeln,
wir müssen es genau in diese Diskussionsrunden einbringen, wir müssen unsere Impulse setzen,
aber, das finde ich ganz wichtig, wir dürfen uns nicht verbiegen.
Wir dürfen dann nicht anfangen, den Politikerinnen und den Politikern nach dem Mund zu reden oder den Wirtschaftsvertretern,
sondern wir müssen da schon sehr selbstbewusst sein.
Aber wir müssen eine Sprache sprechen, die diese Akteure verstehen und wir müssen natürlich auch Forschung machen, die relevant ist.
Es hilft keinem von diesen Akteuren, wenn wir die nächste tolle Theorie oder das nächste tolle theoretische Framework entwickeln.
Sondern wir müssen tatsächlich dann fallbezogen und das ist ein weiteres Mantra der Innovationsforschung und auch der EFI,
wir müssen diese Initiativen, die dann gestoßen werden, wir müssen die begleiten.
Wir brauchen Begleitforschung, die dann nämlich sagen kann, Mensch guck mal hier,
ProBio beispielsweise, das ist also ein Rahmenprogramm des BMBF für das Thema Ausgründung in der Bioökonomie.
Hochrelevant und sehr sehr erfolgreich.
Das wissen wir aber nur, weil wir eine Begleitforschung gemacht haben.
Sie hatten im Vorfeld gesagt, wir wollten vielleicht noch mal auf We Versus Virus zu sprechen kommen.
Da würde ich jetzt drauf einschwenken wollen, genau.
Das war genau so ein Thema, da sind wir herangegangen, also ein Masterstudent und ich,
da sind wir reingegangen und haben das also über Wochen, die das lief, begleitet,
um festzustellen, guck mal, da passiert jetzt etwas.
Vielleicht sollten wir kurz sagen, was es war.
Also zum Beginn der Pandemie, als alle so, oh Gott, was können wir denn jetzt tun,
war es ja eine dieser Initiativen, so einen offenen Hackathon zu machen,
also eine Veranstaltung, wo technikbegeisterte Leute oder gar nicht primär Technik,
aber generell lösungsorientiert über, okay Pandemie, vor welchen Herausforderungen stehen wir denn jetzt,
was können wir denn jetzt hier für Lösungen finden?
Da ist teilweise viel Software erstellt worden, andere Projekte, ich weiß gar nicht, wie breitbandig es war.
Bildungsangebote.
Es war wirklich sehr sehr viel.
Ja, Vernetzungsangebote.
Und das Ganze wurde auch binnen kürzester Zeit auf die Beine gestellt.
Unter anderem auch mit der Hilfe des Prototype-Funds, was ja auch schon so ein Projekt war,
was, sagen wir mal, genau mit solchen Strukturen dann auch schon experimentiert hat unter staatlicher Unterstützung.
Ist schon so ein kleines Innovationspflänzchen gewesen, was schon da war,
was in dem Moment ganz gut gepasst hat, so dass es dann, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie schnell kam das zustande, innerhalb von wenigen Wochen.
Vier bis sechs Wochen, also das war eine erste Idee und dann sind sehr schnell die relevanten Akteure haben sich zusammengefunden
und haben gesagt, wir machen das, wir finden das toll, wir setzen das um.
Es gab die Finanzierung aus dem BMBF, aus dem BMWI und dann ist das einfach losgelaufen.
Also das war tatsächlich auch im Nachgang, gerade wenn Sie mit den Organisatoren sprechen,
die sind da immer noch, die reflektieren das und denken, wir hätten das nicht gedacht,
dass wir das so schnell auf die Beine stellen.
Aber letztendlich hatte das eben genau dieses, das war so ganz agil, kam ja auch aus der IT-Szene,
so Hackathon, Sie sprachen das gerade schon an, so wir machen einfach mal was.
So wir gucken einfach mal, was passiert.
Und unsere Gesellschaft befand sich zu dem Zeitpunkt in einer Situation, wo wir alle das Gefühl hatten, wir müssen jetzt was tun.
Was ist dann passiert?
Dann haben sich diese, so und jetzt hätte ich natürlich im Vorfeld noch mal schön die Zahlen nachschlagen können,
also ich glaube, wir hatten…
Nein, vierstellig hätte ich jetzt gesagt.
Dreistellige Zahl von Teilnehmern auf jeden Fall.
Vierstellig, tatsächlich?
Ja, ich meine schon.
Aber gut, also das ist jetzt das, wo wir beide genau stehen.
Und die haben sich also zusammengetan an einem Wochenende im März und haben gesagt,
so, wir tun uns jetzt mal zusammen und wir geben uns gegenseitig Ideen,
wir sind zusammen kreativ, da sind wir wieder bei diesem Thema Kreativität
und wir überlegen uns, was können wir eigentlich tun, um diese Herausforderungen,
vor denen wir stehen, also wie verbinden wir Leute besser miteinander.
Da hatten wir ja noch das Thema Einkaufshilfen.
Wie sorgen wir dafür, dass die Kinder im Virtuellen unterrichtet werden?
Wie schaffen wir es, womöglich bessere Warnhinweise zu entwickeln?
Wie finden wir womöglich ein Corona-Medikament?
Also ganz unterschiedliche Disziplinen wurden da angesprochen.
Es kamen Menschen aus allen, sage ich mal, Schichten und studiert, nicht studiert,
Informatiker, der Tischler um die Ecke, die sich alle an diesem Wochenende trafen im virtuellen Raum
und gemeinsam Ideen entwickelt haben.
28.000 sagt die Wikipedia.
Fünfstellig, sehen Sie mal.
Ist die Teilnahmezahl. Okay, das ist wirklich eine Menge.
Ja.
Die sich dann in 1500 Projekten damit beschäftigt haben.
Projektteams, genau.
So und da haben wir wirklich eine unglaubliche Bandbreite.
Und am Ende waren wir alle ganz überrascht, begeistert davon, dass es eben so viele gab.
Und dann ging es ja darum, was machen wir jetzt mit diesen 1500 Projekten?
Das soll ja nicht nur so eine Einmalveranstaltung gewesen sein.
Und das haben wir dann eben, das ist ja dann auch über die Initiative, da sind dann eben entsprechende Mentoren angeworben worden,
die Projektteams wurden gefragt, habt ihr Lust das weiter zu machen, habt ihr Zeit dafür?
Wenn nicht, seid ihr bereit, eure Idee sozusagen auf den Marktplatz zu stellen,
dass die von anderen weiter getrieben werden kann?
So und da gab es ganz unterschiedliche Motivationen.
Es gab welche, die gesagt haben, auf alle Fälle machen wir weiter und ich bereit,
da auch in meinem Job zurückzustecken.
Es gab natürlich viele, die während des Lockdowns sehr sehr viel Zeit hatten.
Und so ist das also von verschiedenen Akteuren vorangetrieben worden.
Es gab dann entsprechende finanzielle Unterstützung, es gab dann aber eben auch entsprechende fachliche Unterstützung.
Und ich glaube, mittlerweile haben wir also jetzt, also von 15 Gründungen weiß ich,
aber es kann gut sein, dass da mittlerweile auch schon wieder noch mehr dazu gekommen sind.
Also die dann tatsächlich in die Unternehmensgründung gegangen sind.
Sei es eben jetzt über eine App, die Daten zur Früherkennung von solchen Pandemien zusammenfügt.
Sei es eine App, die eben solche Communitys entsprechend unterstützt,
also vor Ort, so Nachbarschaftshilfen.
Also da gab es eine große Bandbreite.
Es gab zwei oder drei, die jetzt auch in die medizinische Forschung,
ich glaube, zwei sind jetzt am Robert-Koch-Institut angesiedelt,
die da ihre Idee entsprechend jetzt auch in die Forschung übertragen haben, um da eben weiterzumachen.
Und Sie haben das auch forschend begleitet?
Genau. Also wir waren, mein Masterstudent war Teil dieser ersten Runde,
der war an diesem Wochenende mit dabei, hat sich das angeschaut, war völlig begeistert,
ist selber Informatikstudent gewesen und kam anschließend zu mir und sagte,
boah Katharina das war so cool und das ist doch eigentlich spannend, jetzt mal zu gucken,
was passiert damit eigentlich, was kommt da mit raus?
Und das haben wir gemacht.
Wir haben also dann, auf einer Seite hat er in seinem Projektteam weitergearbeitet, an seiner konkreten Idee
und gleichzeitig hat er aber dann eben mit anderen Teams, mit anderen involvierten Menschen
hat er Interviews geführt und hat gefragt, warum hast du mitgemacht?
Was hat dich eigentlich daran gereizt?
Ist das gut gelaufen, was ist an diesem Wochenende gut gelaufen?
Was ist vielleicht nicht so gut gelaufen, was würdest du beim nächsten Mal anders machen?
So und das, was halt rauskam, und da kann man wieder sagen, da sind wir als Wissenschaft nicht so wahnsinnig überrascht gewesen,
der zentrale Faktor war dieses Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl, dieses Community-Feeling.
Ich bin mehr als nur einer oder eine, sondern wir sind eine Gemeinschaft.
Und in dieser Gemeinschaft haben wir Dinge erreicht, von denen ich nicht dachte, dass die möglich wären.
In so kurzer Zeit, in einer solche Kreativität, wir hatten das Gefühl, dass wir sehr viel Unterstützung erfahren haben.
Also dieses gesamte Begleitprogramm ist sehr gelobt worden, dass man das Gefühl hatte,
da gibt es tatsächlich Unterstützung und dann, das ist so der dritte Erfolgsfaktor, wenn wir ihn mal so nennen dürfen,
war tatsächlich das Thema, wir gegen das Virus.
Und da merkt man eben, wie wichtig diese Gemeinsamkeit oder wir nennen es ja dann als Wirtschaftswissenschaftler immer gerne Vision, ist.
Aber sich darauf einzulassen und zu sagen, ja, dafür mache ich das.
Und alle, die hier in diesem virtuellen Raum zusammen sind, die haben alle dieselbe Motivation.
Und das waren so die drei Faktoren, aus denen wir dann eben, und deswegen macht man ja so eine Begleitforschung,
entsprechend Handlungsempfehlungen abgeleitet haben, an die Politik,
aber genauso an Hochschulen, an Schule, an Bürgerinitiativen.
Wenn ihr solche Initiativen machen wollt, solche Hackathons, dann achtet darauf,
findet eine Gemeinsamkeit, findet eine gemeinsame Vision, ein Leitmotiv,
unter das sich die Leute finden können.
Sorgt dafür, dass dieses Gemeinsamkeitsgefühl geschaffen und dann auch aufrechterhalten wird.
Und seht zu, dass ihr dann entsprechende Unterstützung anbieten könnt, um aus diesen Ideen tatsächlich konkrete Dinge machen zu können.
Dass man das Gefühl hat, es verpufft eben nicht einfach so, sondern es kommt wirklich etwas raus.
Findet denn das noch statt, also ist diese Begleitung noch, wir die noch betrieben oder ist das abgeschlossen?
Nein, das ist abgeschlossen.
Hat das gereicht der Zeitraum?
Naja, es war halt der Zeitraum einer Masterarbeit und er hat schon deutlich mehr Zeit reingesteckt,
also er hat acht Monate reingesteckt und wie gesagt, ich sagte ja gerade,
die Projekte laufen teilweise ja immer noch.
Aber uns ging es ja wirklich mehr darum zu verstehen, was sind eigentlich bedeutsame Faktoren,
um so eine Initiative zunächst einmal zum Erfolg zu führen, kurzfristiger Erfolg.
Und insofern würde ich sagen, für diese Fragestellung, mit der er rangegangen ist, hat es erst mal gereicht.
Ja ist so ein bisschen die Dynamik so auch der Hackerszene, da kennt man das ja sehr stark,
diese Community-Ausprägung des Selbermachens, Selberrausfindens, so Eigeninitiative machen
und das Ganze auch über so eine Community zu lenken.
Würde mich noch mal interessieren, was man da jetzt wirklich für Lehren draus ziehen kann,
außer dass das Projekt jetzt an sich toll war.
Weil so, sagen wir mal, dieser Motivationstrieb war natürlich in dem Moment der hereinbrechenden Pandemie,
ist ja auch jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres replizierbar.
Also das ist so eine Ausnahmesituation gewesen.
Also reflektiert schön diese Feststellung, die wir vorhin hatten, mit, es muss erst mal ganz dicke kommen,
bevor irgendwie überhaupt erst mal was passiert.
So ja klar, so globale Pandemie da lässt sich was machen.
Frage ist natürlich, wie kann man das dann im Kleinen mit den normalen Innovationsschüben auch als Lehre heranziehen.
Also was würden Sie denn jetzt sozusagen empfehlen?
Dass solche Hackathons ein wichtiger Faktor sind, um sich überall anzugliedern an den politischen Prozess?
Ist das überhaupt wünschenswert, ist das leistbar?
Wäre die Politik bereit, mit den Erfahrungen, das überhaupt anzunehmen?
Oder bleibt das eher eine einmalige Geschichte?
Ich denke nicht, dass das eine einmalige Geschichte bleibt.
Das, was wir im Moment sehen, ist, die Innovationen der Zukunft sind nicht technologische Innovationen.
Sondern sie werden immer eine Kombination sein aus technologischen und sozialen Innovationen.
Da haben wir wieder diesen Menschenfokus mit drin.
Das weiß die Politik grundsätzlich, die Unternehmen wissen es grundsätzlich auch.
Und wenn es jetzt darum geht, diesen Bereich, den ich jetzt mal Sozialinnovationen nenne
oder Gesellschaftsinnovationen nenne, um das mit reinzukriegen,
werden wir ganz stark eine Bürgergesellschaftsnutzerbeteiligung brauchen.
Ohne die wird es nicht funktionieren.
Da werden wir Disruption nicht durchsetzen können und wir werden vielleicht auch gar nicht erst die Ideen dafür kriegen.
Das heißt, das, was wir aus so einer Initiative lernen können und wir wissen ja,
Bürgerinitiativen gibt es schon ganz lange und es gibt jetzt auch immer diese Labore,
da werden dann Bürgerinnen und Bürger eingeladen und wir wissen auch, es sind immer wieder dieselben Menschen,
die sich engagieren bei so was.
Und es gibt einen ganz großen Anteil an Menschen, die erreichen wir nicht, adressieren wir nicht, die engagieren sich nicht.
Die werden wir aber brauchen.
Und die Erfahrungen und die Lernerfahrung aus so einer Initiative wie „we versus virus“ kann uns helfen,
wenn wir über Politikmaßnahmen, über neue disruptive Technologieinnovationen nachdenken,
von Anfang an mitzudenken, wie sorgen wir dafür, dass wir die Menschen mitnehmen, wie sprechen wir die an?
Wie schaffen wir eine solche Vision, wo die sich vielleicht auch wiederfinden können?
Wie gehen wir früh genug auf diese Akteure zu, um sie einzubinden, um ihre Stimme zu hören?
Um diese Stimme dann aber auch, und das ist ja immer so dieses ganz wichtige, was gerne vergessen wird,
die eben nicht nur einmal zu hören, zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, sondern sie dann auch mit umzusetzen.
Und da braucht es dann natürlich auf beiden Seiten ein Umdenken.
Das sind super Fragen, aber was sind die Antworten darauf?
Wie wir das machen?
Ja.
Pf, das kommt dann ganz drauf an, was wir da jetzt konkret vorhaben.
Naja, also nehmen wir doch mal irgendeinen Bereich heraus, der jetzt nicht die Pandemie ist,
wo wäre denn so ein Vorstoß der Einbindung der Gesellschaft für so innovative Projekte,
vielleicht jetzt nicht in derselben Dimension und nicht mit demselben Druck wie die Pandemiebekämpfung, sondern eben so andere Sachen.
Sagen wir mal Umgestaltung der Städte im Verkehrsbereich.
Richtig, nachhaltige Mobilität.
Betrifft alle enorm, wird viel diskutiert, wenn man so soziale Medien verfolgt, so hier den Beschwerdekanal Twitter zum Beispiel,
da wird also permanent darauf hingewiesen, wie kaputt doch so unser autoorientiertes Verkehrssystem so ist,
habe ich vorhin ja auch schon mal als Beispiel genommen, da sehe ich eine ganze Menge Potenzial.
So und wie geht man dann jetzt vor?
Wie bindet man das denn jetzt ein?
Ich meine, Verkehrsministerium wäre sicherlich ganz gut beraten an der Stelle, konkret wäre ja jetzt mal so ein Vorschlag.
Gut, wie machen wir das denn jetzt mit der Umgestaltung der Städte, damit das nicht irgendwie 30 Jahre dauert,
bis wir da wirklich an den Punkt kommen, weil der Bedarf ist ja offensichtlich da
und es ist ja auch etwas, was die Wirtschaft dann unmittelbar wiederum betrifft.
Da haben wir den Kreis jetzt auch mal geschlossen, nicht wahr, mit der Automobilindustrie,
die sich vielleicht mehr als Mobilitätsindustrie verstehen muss, weil eben ja hier noch ein konkreter infrastruktureller Wandel auch ansteht.
Ja. Also da ganz konkret würde ich eben tatsächlich, Sie haben jetzt die Städte angesprochen,
aber ich würde das wahrscheinlich direkt parallel laufen lassen und würde mir ein städtisches Experimentallabor ausdenken
und würde mir eins im ländlichen Raum aussuchen, denn die Zukunft der Mobilität da müssen wir in Deutschland beides bespielen.
Ja richtig.
Und würde dann sagen, okay Berlin Neukölln und Ostwestfalen-Lippe, so die nehmen wir uns,
da holen wir uns die Bezirkspolitik mit ins Boot und sagen, also ihr werdet jetzt für die nächsten 24 Monate seid ihr unser Zukunftsstandort die Zukunft der Mobilität.
Ihr bekommt Betrag X, fünf, zehn Millionen dafür, dass ihr gemeinsam mit der Wirtschaft vor Ort,
das ist jetzt in Berlin Neukölln nicht so stark ausgeprägt, aber da darf dann vielleicht BMW mitspielen,
wenn Volkswagen nach Ostwestfalen-Lippe geht und ihr macht euch gemeinsam mit diesen vier Parteien,
die ich jetzt schon ein paarmal genannt habe, Wirtschaft, Wissenschaft, Politik und Gesellschaft,
darüber Gedanken, wie ihr das vor Ort umgestalten wollt.
So und dann werden wir unterschiedliche Instrumente bespielen.
Dann werden wir einen Hackathon machen, mindestens einen, wir werden das Ganze also über eine Plattform machen,
wir werden aber genau so mit Bürgerbüros vor Ort arbeiten, wo wir dann vielleicht die nicht so sozialmedienaffinen einladen und sagen,
hier das ist die Vision, das stellen wir uns vor, was sind eure Ideen dazu oder wo seht ihr eigentlich die Probleme?
Die Nutzer mit an den Tisch bringen zu sagen, was sind denn eigentlich eure konkreten Probleme?
Und dann gemeinsam mit denen Lösungen entwickeln.
Und immer unter diesem Kontext, da komme ich jetzt wieder auf diesen einen Erfolgsfaktor,
ihr als Gemeinschaft hier vor Ort in diesen beiden Experimentallaboren könnt die Zukunft so gestalten,
wie sie für euch passt.
Super Idee, wo klopft man da jetzt an, um das durchzusetzen?
Naja, Sie nannten das ja gerade schon, wir haben ja jetzt ein Ministerium für Digitalisierung und Verkehr,
das ist unser erster Faktor, dann nehmen wir das BMBF noch mit rein in die Begleitforschung
und das BMWI für die Startups.
Und dann kommen wir nämlich auf das nächste große Problem, was wir noch nicht gelöst haben
und wo ich mir sehr viel mehr Innovativität gewünscht hätte von der neuen Regierung,
das ist nämlich das Thema interministerielle Zusammenarbeit.
Was es so nicht gibt?
Nein.
Warum?
Das größte, wie sagte mir mal jemand aus einem der Ministerien, also die größte Bestrafung sind die IMAKs,
die interministeriellen Arbeitskreise.
IMAKs?
Mhm /bejahend/, da wird man also abgeordnet, weil ja dann zwischen den Ministerien eine Koordination erfolgen soll
und da kommt überhaupt nichts raus.
Weil, da sind wir wieder relativ zu Beginn, kein Haus will Macht abgeben, kein Haus will die zweite Geige spielen,
kein Haus will im Zweifel zu etwas zustimmen, was das andere Haus bestimmt hat.
So und solange wir das nicht haben, solange die Regierung, die Ministerien sich nicht als ein verantwortlicher Körper versteht,
da werden viele von den Punkten, über die wir gesprochen haben, schwierig umzusetzen sein.
Aber ist doch im Prinzip genau das gleiche Problem, was wir vorhin bei der Wirtschaft auch schon festgemacht haben.
Ja klar.
Dass hier die richtigen Leistungskennzahlen, tolles Wort, Belohnungssysteme vorhanden sind.
Welche Belohnungssysteme könnten denn dann an der Stelle etwas mit reinbringen?
Ja ist richtig, klar.
Wie kann man denn sozusagen belohnt werden, um durch interministerielle Zusammenarbeit trotzdem zu glänzen
und nicht sofort der Später zu sein, der das Budget senkt?
Schwierig, ne?
Sehr sehr schwierig.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es einfach ist.
Ja, also auch da wieder, ich meine, das, was wir da schon als Entwürfe oder mal als Vorschläge entwickelt haben, wäre natürlich,
dann themenspezifische Töpfe, und das wäre jetzt nachhaltige Mobilität, die Zukunft der Mobilität im städtischen und ländlichen Raum,
wohlwissend, dass das Digital- und Verkehrsministerium als erstes schreien würde,
das ist in unserer Verantwortung und gleich sagen, nein, diesen Topf bekommt ihr nur dann, wenn alle dabei sind.
Und dementsprechend werden dann die Gelder verteilt.
Ja, wohlwissend … nein, so und das ist aber jetzt sozusagen meine Milchmädchenrechnung
und ich weiß, dass da noch ganz viele Punkte entsprechend adressiert werden müssen,
aber wir müssen diese Themen aus der ministeriellen Zuordnung und Verantwortung müssen wir rauslösen,
deswegen hoffe ich sehr auf diese sogenannte Hightech- oder Zukunftsstrategie,
da müssten in meinen Augen solche Themen adressiert werden.
Sie müssten mit Zielkennzahlen hinterlegt werden und dann natürlich auch entsprechend mit Budgets.
Und dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich im Zusammenspiel dieser Missionen, nenne ich sie jetzt mal,
vielleicht heißen sie in Zukunft anders, müssen wir dann austarieren, also da darf mal das Ministerium im Lead sein
und da das Ministerium, aber insgesamt muss klar sein, ihr könnt es nur alle zusammen.
Aber das ist ein sehr dickes Brett, weil wir da nämlich genau auf dieses Thema Belohnungsstrukturen, Leistungskennzahlen,
Macht abgeben, zusammenarbeiten, wenn ich womöglich die Sprache des anderen nicht verstehe,
weil das BMWI da ganz anders arbeitet als das BMBF und so weiter.
Aber ich glaube, das wäre ein zentrales Zeichen für uns alle, für die Wirtschaft, für die Gesellschaft,
das bereit ist, über den eigenen Schatten zu springen und zu sagen, Innovation funktioniert nur dann, wenn wir alle mitarbeiten.
Schönes Schlusswort, würde ich sagen an der Stelle.
Könnten jetzt sicherlich noch viel weiter philosophieren und uns fragen, was die Politikwissenschaften hier noch für neue Aufgabenfelder entdeckt haben,
aber vielleicht haben die ja zugehört und denken sich ihren Teil.
Gibt es noch irgendeinen letzten Gedanken, den wir noch hinterher werfen sollten oder können wir es damit beschließen?
Ich glaube, wir können es damit gut beschließen.
Super, dann beschließen wir das damit.
Damit vielen vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit.
Danke Ihnen.
Und vielen Dank für das Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist, bald geht es wieder weiter.
Und ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.